this is how it looks the new mini at the
Oxford plant BMW unveiled the latest
generation of the iconic car since 2001
many has been part of the BMW group the
mini identity is still unmistakably even
though it's been completely redesigned
over the last two years has been a
terrific amount of activity both on site
here in Oxford and in Swindon to get
ready for today 750 million pounds worth
of investment has been spent on new
buildings as in the one we're standing
in at the moment a new plant and
machinery and of course in the people
and the skills that we need looking
forward to build this new car these
investments are part of minis
international growth strategy but the
car remains British through and through
the Oxford final assembly plant will
build up to 900 cars every day some two
and a half million vehicles have come
off this assembly line since the new
mini started production in 2001
in 1959 the original Mini caused an
automotive revolution the cars compact
design was one of the most influential
ever and the car quickly became a style
icon
evangeline spawn cysts BMWs Harlow
cougar says the firm plans to invest 750
million pounds in the entire mini
production triangle by 2015 some 500
million pounds in Oxford and the rest
divided between Swindon and hams all
engine plant the money will go to new
technology such as body construction
we're a thousand new robots are being
installed he says every area of the
factory such as the paint shop will be
state-of-the-art in terms of production
technology as well as sustainability and
environmental protection under the hood
is a completely new generation of
engines from BMW for the first time the
entry-level gasoline and diesel engines
are three cylinder models sporting
TwinPower Turbo technology they offer
improved performance with greatly
reduced fuel consumption but a
four-cylinder hasn't disappeared
completely from the engine range the
cooper s we tested comes with a muscular
four-cylinder gasoline engine that puts
out 141 kilowatts it's prints to 100
kilometers per hour in 6.8 seconds and
as a top speed of 235 while keeping fuel
consumption to 5.7 liters per 100
kilometers I think the exciting thing
about today is but we are here in Oxford
in the heart of mini but that the car
really goes out to the whole world and
we are going to sell it in over 107
countries worldwide so it's not only a
successful in the UK mean it became
really an extremely strong brand around
the world the new mini cooper s has an
unmistakably sporty look starting with
its honeycomb grille which now bears a
chrome s logo it's centrally mounted
tailpipe adds to this pocket rockets pap
the Mini Coopers hood scoop and racing
stripes give it a live athletic profile
the bold contrast between the body
passenger compartment and roof reflect
the brand's iconic design language
it's classic round headlamps are
available as LEDs for the first time a
distinctive mini tradition combined with
high-tech I think important for me as
always you know that this mini we have
basically the combination of tradition
and innovation and if you look a little
bit back when be at the rebirth of a
mini brand in 2001 since then we sold
over 2.5 million minis around the world
so I'm pretty convinced that the product
standing behind me we are going to
continue the success story of me
the high-tech new mini features plenty
of digital networking a controller wheel
with handwriting recognition makes
operating the instrument cluster easier
it has plenty of options that are
usually found only on luxury cars a
head-up display pedestrian warning with
initial brake function adaptive cruise
control traffic sign recognition a
rear-view camera and much more the
colorful arc surrounding the TFT display
emphasizes the youthful design the
latest mini also out does its
predecessor when it comes to luggage
space where 51 liters more room but now
offers 211 liters of capacity the Mini
Cooper S will hit German car showrooms
next spring with a starting price of 23
thousand eight hundred euros
fias world endurance championship or WEC
is still a young racing series first
held in 2012 it conforms to the rules of
the 24 Hours of lamont races take place
on various continents and last anywhere
from six to 24 hours with several
drivers taking turns behind the wheel
this year you have a very intensive
program with the internals with
manufacturers involve on this program
with a very specific spirits coming from
Lamar the beginning and that we can
model eyes and transport all around the
world for different classes meet on the
WEC starting line gte pro and GTE AM are
street legal car is adapted for racing
that can be driven either by
professionals or amateurs known as
gentlemen drivers lmp1 and to our sports
prototypes that are built exclusively
for the race howdy is one of the car
makers taking part
but if it is not a gigantic country song
audi's Wolfgang Ullrich says the wec is
a very special event in endurance racing
one that requires the performance of a
traditional race car over the long haul
it makes it a unique combination of
speed and durability he says a
long-distance race such as a 24-hour
event is like a whole formula one season
compressed into a single weekend howdy
won the previous year's inaugural race
with its r18 e-tron Quattro and the team
appears set to take the world
championship title this year too
although the last race has not yet been
run Audi has built up an unassailable
overall lead and they're helped by the
keen enthusiasm of their drivers and
crew who have all been giving their best
the world chairmanship means a lot for
for all of us I mean I think audi sport
team years is the best team in the world
and to do it over so many races
including the 24 Hours of lamang means
that teamwork really works I mean we
have been together for many years and
always having this hunger to do the
pitstop a few seconds faster to do
everything optimized without making a
mistake this has been very much I think
the key for for a team and our success
of winning a championship which we are
all very proud of toyota is currently
out his only real competition in the
lmp1 class in the GTE Pro Class Audi's
also up against factory teams from
Ferrari Aston Martin and portion
Germany's Jorg Bergmeister is driving a
Porsche 911 rsr number 91 thanks veamos
bought he says the experience is like
driving a sports car anywhere but in a
GT car you have to keep an eye on the
rearview mirror because the faster
prototypes come from behind at the same
time he also has to focus on overtaking
the slower gentleman drivers it means
having to be very attentive in the car
and hopefully not heading anyone being
overtaken isn't something Audi's are 18
has to worry about much with its each
Ron Quattro hybrid concept its front
wheels are powered by 280 kilowatt
electric motors while a 3.7 liter diesel
engine at the rear puts out almost 300
60 kilowatts next year new rules take
effect in which fuel efficiency plays a
much bigger role howdy plans to
introduce a successor card to match the
wec has taken its place among the top
professional racing series and the
audience has a chance to get close to
the action this includes autograph
sessions on the pit 1 Audi driver Allan
McNish is looking forward to taking to
the wheel afterwards sukkot is quite
tight and twisty but the sand is
generally blowing around if you run off
slightly then there's a lot of sign that
goes into the tires there's a big change
in temperatures no it's a little bit
later than the year but that means that
the race runs from daylight to dark and
you've got a big change there so from
the technical point of view it's a very
very hard race here the eighth and final
race of the season has started the
mixture of different classes promises
racing excitement as so many drivers
struggle to overtake one another
if the lmp1 class Toyota refuses to make
things easy for audi cars seventh and
eighth which are also hybrid vehicles
put up an in terment fight against
English Todd's best and a coming year
Porsche plans to compete in this class
for the world championship then the race
goes into the night demanding increased
attention from the drivers
but suddenly on lap 95 car number two is
out of the race it's the first technical
failure of an are 18 and 23 races I
don't know yes we have to find out it's
probably something on the gearbox
the final Bend comes after six hours in
199 laps and this race Toyota can't be
beat Audi's car number one finished a
second but audi still takes the WEC
title they're the new world endurance
champions it's not just endurance racing
that audi fans can look forward to in
2014 the s3 sedan is due to hit
showrooms early next year under the hood
it's 221 kilowatt tfsi engine propels
the s3 from 0 to 100 km/h in just 4.9
seconds the four-cylinder audi sports
the latest technology to improve fuel
efficiency and cut emissions prices for
the s3 in germany started 40 1,050 eros
Porsches new 918 Spyder is a superlative
race car that you could drive home
packing a colosso 652 kilowatts it goes
from 0 to 100 km/h in a mere 2.6 seconds
and tops out at 345 km/h the hybrid is
powered by a 4.8 liter v8 and two
electric motors but that performance
comes at a price the 918 spyder cost
some 800 thousand euros
it's that time of year again cartooning
fans are gathering at the Essen Motor
Show where 500 exhibitors are showing
off the latest trends besides souped-up
cars Motorsports is a big theme at this
year's event there are drift shows and
exhibits to mark the 25th anniversary of
the DTM the most successful German
Touring Car Series but it is not only at
the race track the performance is tested
to its limits the 850 on this Bravo
stands for the horsepower of the six
litre twin-turbo the tuning package
costs 70 thousand euros so buying the
car and the package will set you back
two hundred seventy nine thousand euros
the bravos executive sedan is an office
on wheels
alongside the shiny new cars there are
also many oddities both on four wheels
and two such as this VW Beetle that a
Bosnian pensioner lovingly and carefully
decorated with 20,000 pieces of oak when
it comes to tuning tastes very massively
metallic finnegans actor axel Stein
likes a mat or a foiled finish and big
fat wheels but not much more and there
are certainly plenty of big fat wheels
on display in essen especially at the
show and shine competition
among the competing cars are classic
opals that were made in the rural region
opal has a special place at the Motor
Show
openness in the market place marks who
works for the company says the brand
goes where its clients and fans are both
the essence show and the car
manufacturer are rooted in the Ruhr
Valley and mark says it's the dense
population of the region that keeps opal
their gear fall the company also has
roots and motorsport and is using the
annual motoring event to showcase its
Adam r2 which will be used in a program
for fledgling drivers in the European
rally championships
both the astra gtc and the Corsa OPC
roadsters have a racing car look about
them
let me live
if I open towards according to under
this March there's a lot going on at all
and the brand is enjoying an upswing
consumers have responded positively to
the brand image which brand ambassador
Jurgen Klopp has carried into the world
of soccer but they are also working
towards creating a positive image in the
fields of entertainment and motorsports
opel also has a new brand ambassador
although model loveland doesn't have her
driver's license yet she is looking
forward to her personalized opel adam
but she doesn't want anyone to take her
for her first drive in it she is
determined to do that herself and says
it will just have to wait until she has
passed her test and there is another top
model at the oval stand the Monza
concept the Nifty kupe with the vast
gold wing doors gives an insight into
the future of the brand full of
high-tech and a real looker too boo
this opal is already drawing plenty of
attention
this karmann ghia RS is the only one of
its kind it's part Volkswagen part
Porsche and a lot of fun to drive
jochen badr took the sporty body of a
nineteen seventy karmann ghia and pumped
it full of porsche technology the result
was a hybrid that's second to none Henry
butter tells us that he got the
six-cylinder engine for cheap it had
power to spare was intact and durable so
he thought he'd build a car around it he
knew the motor wouldn't fit into a VW
Beetle but then he thought of a Carmen
and realized could be a perfect fit as I
thought I need mr.
would you like to go for ride I got my
hat that chance is the coming year
originally the Karmann Ghia was a tame
little coupe a with a 50 horsepower
engine in its original condition it
wasn't suited to life in the fast lane
still in the 1960s the little Volkswagen
proved a hit with women on Leyte but
after yahan badr finished pimping it the
team little Kia went wild now his
four-decade obw delivers the performance
of a modern portion the 321 horsepower
3.6 liter cc engine can propel the car
to a top speed of more than 300
kilometers an hour the ghia had good
aerodynamics from the start now even
modern-day sports cars have to make way
for butters karmann ghia RS he's used to
the stunt looks
of em on colorful things mater says even
when he overtakes a Porsche or a Daimler
the drivers are enthused and get a laugh
out of it feedbacks all positive people
give him the thumbs up and tell him it's
cool that a car like this can go so fast
so motor the notion is too far
yes thank you the mechanical design
engineer spent four years creating his
karmann ghia hybrid but he couldn't have
done it without the assistance of stefan
detling and andre as Carla to automotive
engineering students they helped him
with the chassis the brakes and the
aerodynamics and even wrote thesis on
the car
the VW Beetle platform has often proved
a good basis for modifications or
reconstructions and the Karmann Ghia
which was produced from nineteen fifty
six to nineteen seventy-four also
employed Volkswagen technology while it
looked sporty the series production two
plus two seater was hardly a speed demon
its engine produces 50 horsepower at
best and the ghia couldn't go over 150
kilometers an hour still the model
proved a hit over 400,000 rolled off the
assembly lines at carmens factory no
snow Brook before its successor the
Scirocco went into production in 1974
with the exception of the 18-inch wheels
y'all can badas ghia looks pretty much
the same as the series production model
though on closer inspection you can see
the steel roll cage through the rear
window of the wise elkin butter has
remained true to his motto why draw
attention to yourself unnecessarily the
most flamboyant part of the car is found
under the hood an air-cooled 6-cylinder
boxer engine from the Porsche 993 after
undergoing various modifications the 3.6
liter motor produces a whopping 321
horsepower and that distinctive porsche
sound too
the interior is very minimalist jochen
bata has integrated a tube frame into
the Karman body to improve stability and
safety this framework supports all of
the porsche technology hidden underneath
the VW body are the front and rear axles
of a porsche 944 turbo the car has cost
him plenty of money and sleepless nights
but for your fan bottom it was all worth
the effort
the lion thinkin selector was he says
for as long as he can remember people
have dreamed of being the wolf in
sheep's clothing it started in the 70s
with the beetle but it's harder with a
new generation of cars like the golf
which are already fast he feels it's
boring just to make them go faster no
one gives a hoot about that let take a
40 year old car like this which no one
thinks can do over a hundred kilometers
an hour he says then it's something when
you're doing 200 klicks and then shift
into fifth gear knowing you still have a
660 jochen Badr shows us just what the
car can do on a stretch of road that's
been blocked off he loves to push the
car to its limits and doesn't much care
what purist think of his Porsche powered
creation his karmann ghia RS is a
one-of-a-kind creation that runs circles
around the rest